MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, it's getting pretty late.
I think that was a
pretty good take,
so let's just do one more, and
then we'll be out for the day.
OK, Rob?
ROB: All right.
[HEAVY DRUMS START AND STOP]
MALE SPEAKER: Three.
Two.
[HEAVY DRUMS START AND STOP]
ROB: Otherwise, as always--
DAVID EAST: Hey, Rob.
ROB: [CLEARS THROAT]
Oh, hey.
What's up, David?
DAVID EAST: Well,
uh, did I tell you
that I got my own YouTube show?
ROB: Oh, no, dude.
That's awesome.
What's it, uh-- what's
it going to be about?
DAVID EAST: So,
like, you know, I
was thinking there's not a
lot of screencast content
out there.
And so I'm going to go and
make a bunch of screencasts
on Firebase.
ROB: Well, that's sort of
exactly what we're doing here
for "Polycasts," a show about--
DAVID EAST: It's nothing
like that, really.
Like I said, my show is
going to be on Firebase.
You know, like, building
real-time, cross-platform apps
without any server code.
ROB: Well, I have
all this equipment,
and I have this crew.
So if you want, I can show
you the ropes some time.
So like how you put the--
DAVID EAST: So I was thinking
of calling it "Firecasts,"
you know?
Like the Firebase
is for the "fire."
ROB: Yeah, Firebase, yeah.
DAVID EAST: And, you
know, like, the "cast"
comes from screencast.
ROB: Screencasting.
Yes.
DAVID EAST: What do you think?
[MUSIC PLAYING]